[Music]
at 93 he's just a few years younger than
queen elizabeth and for laura dennis
this special jubilee lunch in east
london was a chance to entertain the
community
these people i've i've brought up me and
no no
you know
all old family friends and much younger
than me by the way
no i just wanted to do it
[Music]
pensioners gather at this centre for a
free traditional lunch and a sing-song
but they were joined by other residents
for the last day of the four-day jubilee
i do remember the silver jubilee when i
was young it was probably about seven
and this feels quite like similar to
that it's gone a lot more
community-based what they would like for
this to carry on not every year maybe
but just to get together with
communities and to be some legacy there
for the older generation the queen's
been a force of stability ever since her
accession to the throne 70 years ago
people like michael who's received
numerous awards for his time in the army
the last of them being a special
platinum jubilee medal
we love the queen
we love being having a royal family
and we love the community spirit that it
brings together
for each and every one of us
[Music]
and the queen can do that and she does
do it every day
there have been events like this at
community centres and in residential
streets across the country
and even for people who don't consider
themselves staunch royalists many will
tell you it's a great chance for the
generations to come together
and for those too young to remember even
the diamond jubilee 10 years ago there
were other attractions too and what's
the best thing about today
oh definitely the cake
oh yeah the cake
i think i'm supposed no
cakes of all shapes and sizes were on
offer at the oval cricket ground in
south london prince charles the heir to
the throne and his wife camilla were
here for a somewhat bigger jubilee lunch
and at windsor castle crowds gathered to
try to break the world record for the
longest picnic
but for thousands of people it was about
keeping it local as well as marking a
milestone
[Music]
nadeem baba al-jazeera london